I sort of got every day I like more and
more like that bull s'eye that's all got
more views on his one video than my
whole channel there's no intro to this
I'm just gonna get right into it I don't
get it and I'm gonna be completely
honest with you know anything about guys
anymore in the past few years there's
been somebody I don't know which was
right for example my life colorful
eating cereal was good for you your
cereal David it has vitamins at Morello
flavin and came up and said hey guess
what burials bad it has car hey you
Google take cereal away from me that was
the last healthy offer that tasted good
and now you gonna tell me that's the
reason why I'm mad potentially you know
what cereal is to a dental child that
[ __ ] breakfast lunch and dinner and now
you tell me to go tell Captain Crunch to
go [ __ ] himself
no Joe go be back with your new chapter
crunch where that little leprechaun and
that cute little homosexual rabbit wait
before I do you mr. fat inside that's
right I don't like packets you'll love
Atkins it's basically all meat his thing
that you have to understand why isn't
that every single fit person thinks that
all fat people hate vegetables we don't
hate vegetables we just eat it with a
lot of other [ __ ] I don't give a Beyonce
nipple about that what you telling me
that I can't have rice noodles is Baba
the most offensive thing you could have
ever said to an ancient person this one
residue came up to me and told me that
rises at me I said then my Korean accent
came out of nowhere
hey bro did you give that rice is bad
for you no you don't stand on one sheet
sticky something if rice is so bad for
you then why the hell are there so many
skinny people in Asia then huh ha hey
you guys all the time but they way
my left butt cheek I dare you to tell an
Italian person not be popular and see
what happens like you ever wonder what
would happen if Princess Toadstool told
Mario that he could be popular anymore
Super Mario no more pasta for you it's
bad
Oh what does business sir tell me I can
have pasta [ __ ] up in a hatchery by the
Seine turtle for the past 50 years and
you still ain't learned [ __ ] but worry
about yourself you know what I hate even
more than all these crazy-ass nights
when someone who is 10 times better than
I am trying to give me weight loss
advice [ __ ] flip you take a
cheeseburger and slap the [ __ ] out of
yourself with it don't tell me how to
lose weight when you're so fat your
kneecaps and your ankle uh connect if
you knew how to lose weight you will be
taking your own advice
Andre the mother Jack your bear sitting
over there judging me bid you to french
fries away from getting diagnosed with
hepatitis chunky you know you know what
else I don't like people who they eat
whatever they want and look great and I
know what a lot of you gonna say they
may be skinny but they're not healthy on
the inside David is that what you want
healthy the only difference is you look
good you ever notice when you're fat
everything look better on you I hate it
when you're walking down the street and
you see some skinny ass dude when it's a
nice that [ __ ] and you're like maybe I
can wear that too but for some reason
when he wears it either like this and
then when you wear you look like this
[ __ ] I just wanna be fed you know what
this is what I want I want to be able to
walk them through stairs without
questioning my religion you have to be
in so much pain you stop wondering if
God existed [ __ ] Jesus Buddha god Vishnu
anybody got me all of Yellen made me
hungry
would you snicker let me see let me see
let me see oh my
keep it f and G let me see let me see
let me do my and keep your f and g
[Music]